in less than three decades Helen Hunt
has gone from the very top of the film
industry to well a lot of places both in
and out of Hollywood breakups are a
common part of adulthood even so Helen
Hunt surprised many in 2017 by calling
things off with her boyfriend of 16
years producer Matthew carahan the two
had been together since 2001 and even
welcomed a daughter together in 2004 and
yet despite InTouch weekly reporting
that hunt and carahan appeared to be
crazy for each other they couldn't keep
their spark alive forever according to a
source who spoke to the Tabloid their
separation was pretty turbulent that
same Source revealed that the pair had
done this several times before recalling
Matthew moved out a few times over the
years Helen would always take him back
and then time would pass and she'd kick
him out again now however it seems
they're done for real and even their
mutual love for their daughter mcka Le
Gordon carahan couldn't keep them
together any longer on May 13th 2004 4
shortly before her 41st birthday Helen
Hunt gave birth to mcka given this was
such a big change in her life it's
unsurprising that hunt pulled back from
the Hollywood grindstone for a while
after four decades without kids it's
completely understandable that hunt
wanted to stay home more to raise her
first born in fact even during her rare
foray back into the public eye during
mck's childhood her Focus was still very
much on her daughter she even spent the
entire duration of a 2013 interview with
the independent knitting a doll for her
daughter while Fielding questions about
how a movie she starred in would do in
the upcoming award season now that mcka
is a legal adult we may start to see
more of her mother in the celebrity
world again however given that mcka
remains her only child we wouldn't be
surprised if hunt continued to dedicate
massive amounts of her energy toward the
continued love and support of her
daughter mcka is already embarking on
her own creative Endeavors as a
songwriter and as a fellow artist it
would only make sense that hunt would
want to continue a close relationship
with her daughter as she transitions
into adulthood and the two of them write
the songs together and they I just hear
them downstairs like laughing or they'll
write some sad lyric and then I hear
that's cool in the time since her Heyday
at the turn of the century Helen Hunt
never outright stopped making movies
however with a few exceptions odds are a
large portion of her longtime fans may
not have heard of most of those projects
at the height of her career hunt started
in fil films like 1997's as good as it
gets and the combination of her Charisma
and chemistry with co-star Jack
Nicholson netted the romcom almost $315
million worldwide a year before that she
was in twister a disaster epic that
grossed almost $500 million right after
her sitcom mad about you ended she
started in 2000's what women want and
Cast Away which took in $375 million and
$430 million
respectively I'm going to miss the
excitement but I'll handle it throughout
the a she also starred in films like the
curse of the Jade Scorpion Dr TM the
women and Bobby all of which failed to
impress movie goers critically her Rock
Bottom moment has to be 2010's every day
which opened in three theaters never
made it past 4 and ultimately grossed a
poultry $
46,2 over 10 weeks this film in
particular was a pretty serious
disappointment as it marked Hunt's
returned to the screen after a 3-year
Hiatus in an interview with The Daily
Beast Helen Hunt said that part of the
reason she shifted into low gear after
her late '90s boom was due to her Oscar
win for As Good As It Gets she explained
that after making an arrangement with
Sony she began writing heavily between
acting gigs around this time she
received a copy of Elanor litman's novel
then she found me and she began working
hard to adapt it against the changing
tide of the film industry hunt recalled
i' just been in the last big wave of
movies about people talking to each
other and trying to love each other so
as that was shrinking I was trying to
make one of those movies so I kept
rewriting it subtly as a result of the
Public's changing taste Studios stopped
funding the style of movies hunt was
known for the actress elaborated that in
turn she got pretty tired of making
romantic comedies herself so it was
pretty apt timing for a change in her
creative
Pursuits despite the change ing time
hunt wound up using her adaptation of
and then she found me as her first foray
into directing and starring in a film
unfortunately the 2007 dramedy and hunts
performance in particular fell flat with
critics One reviewer for the Los Angeles
Times wrote the problem isn't so much
the character of April as it is the way
hunt plays her a little too whiny a
little too angry to be very sympathetic
hunt has a tendency to play up those
characteristics in just about everything
she does Hunt's debut as a director was
also criticized with Christy Des Smith
of the Minneapolis Star Tribune calling
her Direction heavy-handed before
expanding that her acting performance
was also lackluster after her
featurelength directorial debut failed
critically hunt took a long break from
directing then over the past decade she
began pursuing the art form in Earnest
once again any thoughts on how recently
she's focused mainly on television
overseeing an episode of California two
episodes of Revenge two of life in
pieces and one each of House of Lies
This Is Us and Feud bet and Joan in 2014
she directed her second film with ride
while it wasn't her best creative effort
to date earning only 52% on Rotten
Tomatoes she's clearly working hard to
get better at her new profession and
will only improve over time before Bobby
and then she found me critics also tore
apart a good woman a a film adaptation
of an Oscar Wild play speaking to past
magazine hunt explained that she Drew
great inspiration from the play and its
lead role saying it has all the ear
marks of a really good part I certainly
saw in there the potential for a
character I haven't seen in a little
while hunt played the seductive Mrs
erlin while the part in question may
have been juicy critics didn't exactly
love what hunt did with it a review by
the AV club criticized the actor's
performance as embarrassing out of place
with many of her mannerisms lacking the
sensual Allure the role called for
another harsh review in the Seattle
Times noted Hunt is completely at Sea
here flatly intoning her lines as if
she'd memorized them phonetically it's a
mystifyingly bad performance and it
drags down the entire movie with reviews
like that coming in we'd probably
consider taking a step away from the big
screen as well even before her film
career blew up Helen Hunt slowed her
professional Pace in the wake of mad
about you one possible explanation for
why she did this is that she'd simply
made a lot of money with a successful
show already under her belt she had
little need to work unless she really
wanted to for this reason she could also
afford to be picky regarding potential
roles Hunt's wealth increased
magnificently in May 1998 as she and her
madabout you co-star Paul Riser
negotiated pay raises from
$250,000 an episode to an Incredible 1
million ion per episode though this
paygrade only lasted them through the
final season its 22 Episodes still
netted both of them over eight figures
once you factor those paychecks in with
the money she'd made starring in
Hollywood Blockbusters you can see how
acting has given her Wealth Beyond most
anyone's wildest dreams so next time
you're wondering why Helen Hunt isn't
everywhere anymore the answer might just
be she doesn't have to be one of the
hardest things for anyone to face is the
the death of a family member and in 2016
hunt suffered the loss of her father on
December 17th of that year Gordon hunt
famed director of cartoons and
liveaction television passed away at the
age of 87 according to the Hollywood
Reporter he had been suffering from
Parkinson's disease prior to his death
Gordon hunt had his foot in many doors
of the entertainment industry and even
worked with some of the biggest names in
Hollywood today Gordon hunt was my
acting teacher when I was in LA for a
couple years it may not surprise Avid
hunt fans that Gordon actually directed
31 episodes of Mad About You in fact he
even directed the episode in which his
daughter's character gave birth which
must have been quite a surreal
experience for both the actress and her
father speaking to The Hollywood
Reporter hunt said of her father if you
asked 100 people who knew him 100 of
them would say he was the kindest man
they ever knew even before his death she
honored him by dedicating her 2014
surfing film ride to him reportedly
Gordon was an active body Surfer from
the 1930s until just a few years before
his death in addition to her illustrious
film and TV career hunt has also been a
very public advocate for women's rights
in 2012 hunt appeared on NBC's who do
you think you are a show showing
celebrities learning about their family
tree during her appearance on the show
hunt learned that her great great
grandmother was a pivotal figure in the
battle for women's equality this
Revelation must have ignited a spark in
in Hunt as she's been vocal about
women's rights both in and out of
Hollywood since during a 2015 interview
with the Huffington Post hunt was openly
critical of The Limited range of roles
available to women of all ages she
criticized the industry for its lacking
amount of stories with strong female
leads and how even projects as simple as
billboard advertisements often try to
sexualize models and actresses for no
logical reason she later made her stance
further known by joining the women's
march to protest the inauguration of
Donald Trump in response to the
derogatory things he said about women
before and during his campaign even if
hunt never acts again she certainly got
plenty of work ahead of her in
philanthropy in 2017 Helen Hunt was
primed for a cinematic comeback after
being tapped for a major role in a new
film written and directed by Lou CK the
black and white I love you Daddy starred
CK as a TV writer who doesn't know what
to do when his young daughter played by
Khloe Grace morrettes starts to dat to
significantly older and famously sleazy
filmmaker played by Donn malovich hunt
co-starred in the film playing the
ex-wife to CK's character and mother of
moretz's I love you Daddy was set for a
star studed Premiere in New York on
November 17th 2017 but the event was
canceled at the last minute after the
New York Times published accounts of
five women who accused CK of sexual
misconduct a subsequent theatrical
release was immediately taken off the
table as well bought back the rights to
the film
in November 2019 Helen Hunt returned to
the role of Jamie for the reboot of Mad
About You her time on the original show
not only made her famous but netted her
four Emmy Awards and three Golden Globes
once we got into the space it felt
wildly familiar while its initial run on
NBC ended in 1999 it came back to TV on
the tail end of the reboot craze that
saw other '90s hits like Twin Peaks the
xfiles and Rosanne return to open art
Med viewers the 12 new episodes of the
series focused on the once young and
newlywed Jamie and Paul wondering what
to do with themselves after their only
child leaves for college Mt about you
version 2.0 however just didn't click as
well as its fellow revived Classics
earning a midling 42% rating from
Critics on Rotten Tomatoes if fans
wanted to watch it it was also kind of
hard for them to find the season aired
on Spectrum Originals a relatively
obscure Network that serves as the
Showcase channel for a cable company in
2017 Helen Hunt found herself at the
center of an international controversy
she agreed to participate in an event
known as the world Youth Forum which
took place in sham alake a resort City
in Egypt as a high-profile celebrity
hunt was made a featured speaker at the
opening ceremony from the outside her
participation seems completely harmless
or even commendable as the world Youth
Forum presents itself as a humanitarian
group aiming to improv the state of the
world for the younger Generations the
controversy stems from the events ties
to Egyptian president abdal fata alisi
who has been labeled as a dictator by
activist groups in Egypt and elsewhere
in the world more than 100 individuals
including many prominent human rights
activists signed a joint letter
condemning Hunt's involvement in the
event the activists called hunt out
directly by saying as you shake hands
with CeCe smile take a photo let history
note that you chose to support a
dictator responsible for thousands of
deaths arbitrary detentions and
disappearances the arbitrary detentions
mentioned in the letter refer to the
wrongful imprisonment of journalists and
lgbtq plus individuals at the hands of
LC's Administration it is possible that
hunt signed up for what she thought was
a humanitarian event without being aware
of the controversy that would follow but
she was certainly made aware of it after
the huge backlash became public
nevertheless Hunt went ahead and gave
her speech at the world Youth Forum all
the same in the early days of the co 19
pandemic the film industry shut down
completely causing the production of
many films to be delayed as everyone
went into lockdown slowly but surely
projects with contained locations and
limited casts began coming together
again until the industry found its
footing once more one of the first films
to come out of the social distancing era
of the pandemic was How It Ends the film
was written and directed by Daryl wine
and Zoe lisst Jones the latter of whom
also starred in the film as the title
implies the film is a comedy about the
end of the world but rather than fully
embracing the medical threat of the co
19 pandemic the virus was swapped for a
meteor headed toward Earth do you
actually believe in the news the meteor
is fake While most of the smallscale
movies made during this first phase of
the pandemic kept their casts as Tiny as
possible for practical reasons How It
Ends went in the opposite direction the
film was packed with a slew of stars
including Olivia Wild Charlie Day
Bradley Whitford Colin Hanks Fred
armison Logan Marshall Green Whitney
Cummings Finn wolfard and of course
Helen Hunt the film takes place almost
entirely outside with the cast observing
social distancing guidelines it mostly
unfolds like a series of vignettes as
liser Jones walks through empty streets
during lockdown it never aimed to be
anything more than a bit of harmless fun
during a trying time for the industry
and the film didn't have much of a shelf
life beyond the era in which which it
was made what's more the film's
lackluster Legacy was surely cemented by
the release of don't look up a much
higher budget movie with an almost
identical concept that came out the very
same year 1996's twister was one of the
biggest box office hits of Helen Hunt's
career the film was the second highest
grossing movie of the year blowing all
of the competition out of the water
except for Independence Day more than
two decades later a potential sequel
Looms on the horizon but not the one
hunt would have liked after working on
the original film in front of the camera
only hunt wanted to expand her
involvement in the sequel she wrote a
script for twister 2 alongside her blind
spotting collaborators David Diggs and
Raphael Cal hunt also planned to direct
the sequel herself but could not find a
studio willing to play ball hunt and
Diggs both pointed to the script's
emphasis on diversity as the possible
reason why it was a non-starter for the
studio speaking to Insider hunt
explained I tried to get it made with
David and Raphael and me writing it and
all black and brown stormchasers and
they wouldn't do it later on in the
interview Diggs elaborated that a factor
for why the movie was never made was for
a quote shady reason that he found to be
a typical issue in the Contemporary film
industry a completely different twister
sequel titled Twisters is currently in
the works with an expected release date
of Summer 2024 the plot is said to
revolve around the daughter of the main
characters played by hunt and Bill
Paxton in the original the bulk of the
cast of Twisters has already been
publicly announced but Hunt's name is
not on the list while a reason for
Hunt's absence has yet to be publicly
announced it's possible she simply
wasn't asked to return or that she chose
not to reprise her role after her own
sequel script was rejected for all we
know she could even be involved with
twisters in an unexpected way but her
presence is being kept under wraps for
the time being regardless it seems that
Hunt's initial vision for a twister
sequel will never come to life
[Music]
n